you know i've been looking at anti-work
and work reform on reddit for you know
months now and they're saying like you
know workers of the world unite where
where are these leftist subreddits when
the workers are uniting hold on the
anti-work reddit says why don't they say
like non-workers of the world yeah
really their whole thing the funny thing
is that anti-work initially was
this this radical idea that no one
should work what a job it's the
stupidest thing ever and they try and
act like they're smart they're like well
i was reading a book by marks and he
explains capital when reality they're
like lazy you know living in their trash
departments on you know government
benefits and they're saying like but i
don't want to walk dogs anymore 20 hours
a week we saw that on fox and that was a
pr disaster for them but it
anti-work evolved into a work reform
subreddit
after the whole debacle where they did
this interview on fox and were exposed
as being
people who just didn't want to do any
work and were kind of lazy
uh the work reform subreddit took off
now i agree with with a lot of work
reform i think you know the corporate
structure in a lot of ways a lot of
really bad things i think student loan
debt has reached critical mass and the
whole system is broken it has been
totally reformed
but why aren't these people coming out
and being like hey look the workers are
finally rising up this is a really good
thing why don't we we stand in
solidarity with the working class oh
because the actual working class don't
believe in their far left psychosis
their their insane policies they never
have well i mean i think we've we got
the first taste of this after trump was
elected it became apparent that
right-leaning people tend to be more in
touch with what your average working
person actually wants and the democratic
party doesn't really represent those
people now it's as clear as it's ever
been but this was not our our first view
of this
i when i in like 2018 i had an
opportunity to go back to ohio and live
in ohio for a little while i'd been in
like la before that new york chicago i'd
been in these big cities and at first i
was back and like i was living in a farm
town in ohio and my friends were like
trump trump and i'm like trump why
what's going on
what and and it's just it hurt it was
like being in like some sort of acid
like a pool of acid it was burning me
but i came out so much stronger because
i wasn't being manipulated anymore i was
seeing things from this other like
workers perspective that i'd been
just lost it'd been lost to me in the
big city for 15 years it was
really incredible the power of the
worker man i want to show you guys this
uh this subreddit post from lockdown
critical left yes this is amazing from
two days ago cool spectre wrote workers
are uniting in solidarity against an
authoritarian government and the left is
against it the trucker convoy is the
closest thing to a working class
uprising i've seen in my lifetime i
wasn't around in the 60s and yet the
left is somehow against it isn't this
exactly the kind of thing the left
should be supporting are there even any
working class people on the left anymore
why do they all seem to be zoom tech
workers or unemployed why is the actual
working class overwhelmingly not on the
left it's really unsettling to see
actual working class unity taking direct
action against fascist mandates and the
left is taking the side of the fascists
except for those of us who have been
watching for the past 10 years it's
exactly what's been happening the whole
time yeah well it's also i mean to add
another layer here you have the left
literally after uh you know two years
after the the summer of love and these
protests
and all of this anti-police rhetoric
they are now like begging the police to
come in and crack down on a workers well
i guess
yeah now it's atab um it is canada so
you know to be fair it's a different
country but you're right they have blm
protests in canada too yeah and trudeau
stood with them and i'm sorry i'm sorry
kneeled with them
with them yeah so so he bent the knee
why isn't the working class returning
the favor right but of course it's
because blm and these leftist groups
never represented the working class in
the first place yeah so my favorite
author is terry pratchett and he has the
perfect quote about this he says people
on the side of the people capital t
capital p always ended up disappointed
in any case they found that the people
tended not to be grateful or
appreciative or forward thinking or
obedient the people tended to be
small-minded and conservative and not
very clever and were even distrustful of
cleverness and so the children of the
revolution were faced with the age-old
problem it wasn't that you had the wrong
kind of government which was obvious but
that you had the wrong kind of people
and i think that's the left is
discovering entirely i think they've
known this yes for a long time it's why
there was this really funny moment where
in seattle some like socialists came out
and were protesting against amazon and
then some trade workers like
construction guys and contractors showed
up in their vests and hard hats and
started chanting them down
because they were the actual
working-class guys these intelligentsia
you know college graduate types think
they're working class they're quite
literally not they're the intelligentsia
i represent the working class well no
yeah it's also funny because um
the left has always tried to say that
they represented the working class but
then they'll take all of these wildly
unpopular social positions that your
average working person does not believe
in it all and then try to force it on
them so it's like
even with situations outside of this i'm
pro-working class except i think a
working-class person should lose their
job for stating something in a public
forum that literally every other
working-class person believes about
transgenderism for example yeah like
like whoopi goldberg you know they
suspend her she's a good working class
one that's right and they come after her
culture
so obvious because it really is about
money here she is making a humble 96 000
per week yes per week per week and of
course because she has six figures yeah
not even six figures per week per week
and so she can't defend herself and so
she gets suspended for two weeks it's
terrible heavens
when will the workers rise up you know
but but i bring that up real quick just
cause as a good example of what happens
to be goldberg when she doubles down on
offensive comments gina carano on the
other hand who didn't say anything
offensive she said don't demonize your
neighbor she loses her job
i thought that whoopi thing was an
example of um critical race theory
having gone too far it went too far
because she all of a sudden is now
starting to think that if someone is the
same skin color as someone else that
they're the same race skin color has
nothing to do with race maybe not maybe
it's not safe to say maybe it's not safe
to say nothing but if you take someone
out of a place on earth and put them
somewhere else within two or three
generations their skin color is going to
be different their kids their grandkids
are going to look way different than if
you put them in like sub-saharan africa
let me let me try and help you out ian
and by this making this point there
there are uh asian cultures that look
very similar to native american cultures
even though they're they're very
different i came across the bering
strait 13 000 years ago and so it's not
necessarily like you you could be a
different race or ethnicity and look
very similar to so skin color and race
are not the same thing but they are
connected you know you could say that
they're court there's a correlation
there it's it's really uh offensive and
egregious that she would make that claim
yeah yeah so there was
related to the way that the left views
the working class there was this book
that i read when i was 17 that really
informed my view on this and it's called
intellectuals by paul johnson and he
sort of goes through
the lives of many of the people who are
held up as like the foundation or the
foundational thinkers
of modern society and what he points out
is that so often these are people who
claim to love humanity in the abstract
but in their personal relationships when
they dealt with actual humans they
tended to treat them like garbage
and i think there's a parallel here
because the left tends to be much more
likely to say i want to change the
entire world i want to reshape the
entire society and change how people
think about things change the way people
treat each other and i think
conservatives are much more likely to
err on the side of subsidiarity
subsidiary and try to change what's
around them as opposed to going for the
world as a whole because they're more
interested in actual individual people
and so these lefties have this idea in
their head of what the working class is
as an abstraction and then when they
have to deal with actual working-class
people and their desires they come to
realize that human beings are messy and
they require that you sacrifice your own
will in order to care for them and
they're not willing to do that you know
i wonder if you know marx has some good
points about capital and stuff and i
wonder if uh
ultimately a bad ideology i'm just but
you know it's it's broken clock is right
twice a day but my point is you get
these these college graduate people that
some of the some of the highest salary
earners in the country in the world
and they're greedy
and jealous
and angry and purposeless so they feel
like something is wrong something is
wrong with my life then they read you
know das capital or whatever and they're
like he's talking about me yes because i
hate my life he's literally not talking
about you you are the one
let's let's just be real the
intelligence are the ones who get
executed because they're threats to the
revolution oh yeah no as soon as the new
revolutionary sect rises the power they
end up taking out all the people that
fought for the revolution in the first
place because those are agitators they
were the ones who fermented revolution
exactly yeah
can't have those people in your system
nope well we have this uh this other
post from reddit it's called the counter
protest from rslash ottawa hello
everyone my name is mackenzie and i am
not afraid this saturday i will be
organizing the peaceful counter protest
against the terrorists
occupying our city center terrorist
terrorism is defined as the unlawful use
of violence and intimidation especially
against civilians in the pursuit of
political aims people are afraid our
downtown workers are afraid to go to
work the police is afraid the police is
afraid to act
the city has denied me an official
protest permit citing covet concerns i
am not afraid
no you're a fascist oh can i say them
literally a fascist also can can i say
like the most boring thing in the world
but i think needs to be said here like
where where was this kind of talk during
the blm riots like how does that not fit
the definition of terrorism when
buildings are being burnt down i don't
believe this is a real person i don't i
you know i mean it's probably
but come on you know i'm reading some of
these posts on facebook from lefties and
i'm like dude you don't actually believe
what you're saying right like you can't
be that psychotic no they are
yeah it's amazing well well
what really is pissing me off right now
is how they're like the school banned
the book mouse and i'm like they
literally didn't ban the book they
removed it from the curriculum you know
what does that mean the gulag
archipelago has been banned as well oh
no they're banning those
oh they're banning you know
anti-communist propaganda what do we do
no it's just not part of the curriculum
you know what i would say uh to everyone
who's upset about mouse i think and
here's an idea we should have curriculum
transparency to ensure those right-wing
fascists don't go meddling with
curriculums in ways that parents aren't
aware of we should have curriculum
transparency i just saw that there was
that makes you far right yeah that makes
you feel right
so making the students curriculum
transparent to the world is that what it
is or just to the parents to the parents
into the community yeah to the community
meaning like it's on the internet for me
to go look at what anyone could see
right i'm open to open source of course
yeah here's something i don't know do
you guys know how many books are in a
curriculum
that that's that's like a curriculum is
like something they want you to read
throughout the year whatever yeah it
can't be that many yeah it's like four
or five maybe really just four or five
well i think maybe per class or
something yeah per class yeah like per
english class so so you know i i don't
want to get wrapped up in that whole
mouse conversation again but you know
just in the context of what these people
are saying when i see this post and it's
like i am not afraid these people are
terrorists it's like dude they're
honking car horns calm down
yeah you wouldn't have to say i'm not
afraid if you weren't afraid you
wouldn't be saying that you're obviously
afraid that's why no no no i am not
afraid no i don't think it's i don't
think it's a real person you think it's
an ai no no a slider
[Applause]
if you put it all the way to the left it
gets you fired from your job what i mean
is this person is lying
they're crafting a political message for
political reasons man i can't put
anything past anybody these days
i was buying it really mm-hmm
because you've seen stuff like this
before no no what you were saying about
the scale yeah i think it might be an ai
yeah yeah i took the political compass
no this is
well crafted by a person and it's
probably someone who is
you know liberal left whatever the
canadians call themselves they don't
have democrats or whatever and they're
it's their their version of
establishment communist elite type
authoritarian across the board and they
were like what can we do to push back
against this worker uprising
let's do a popular message let's post
into you know the city subreddit and
then make people think it's a popular
thing for a regular person a regular
person who's like honking your horns is
terrorism
yeah
no but when black lives matter caused 2
billion dollars in damages and killed
around 30 people
maybe then we can call it terrorism
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time